rosa vous êtes à la traîne pour suivre
un régime sui nord si vous avez un
infarctus je vous opère pas de sitôt
mais ce jeu repose sur tous les bons
moments que nous avons passés ensemble
ces dix dernières années
et alors il ment et continuer seul
l'autre jour j'ai vu un documentaire sur
les amibes et à certains exemplaires qui
ont une vie bien plus actif que la
sienne je pars demain tu avais pas d
examen le moment je préfère arrêter
métier j'ai décidé d'entrer au séminaire
est de devenir curé un fils prêtre
ce serait commettre rémouleur joueur de
cornemuse et moi je ne veux pas d'avis
joueur de cornemuse
dis-moi pas paraphé dit tu comprend
quelque chose doit maintenant non parce
que j'ai téléchargé jésus de nazareth
est très fort dans le film de céférina
tu l'as vue ne raconte pas la fin c'est
don pietro qui a tout organisé
et puis c'est une fois que jésus l'a
retrouvé les disciples et eux et les
pensées traître et il est plutôt mignon
nous mais c'est lui le prêtre c'est une
couverture dès que je découvre je
balance toi mon fils est le problème est
résolu et commente une affaire
vendredi vous devrez interpréter le rôle
de massage confiante et qu'est ce que
vous dites je m'excuse j'ai donc les
trop je suis désespéré j'ai un frère est
un deadline honneur de ma femme qui est
des fois elle mais je pense aussi à
supprimer c'est le moins qu'ils puissent
faire c'est commenter de prêtres n'est
pas je te dirais que c'est vraiment sion
travailler le dimanche moi ça va mais
non je rigole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]